hi everyone in this video we are going
to talk about splicing process we know
in case of eukaryotic genes we have
introns and exons now the exons are
shorter whereas the introns are the
intervening sequences between two exon
and they are bigger in size now when
eukaryotes transcribe their genes to
mRNA then what happens in the mRNA as
well there would be a sequence
corresponding to intron and there would
be sequence corresponding to exon and
this kind of mRNA is actually known as
heteronuclear RNA and it's not the
processed version after that this hñ RNA
would be processed and the intervening
intron sequence would be removed and the
exons would be joined and this process
is known as splicing splicing means
simply cutting out that means the
process by which the introns are chopped
off is known as splicing but even if it
sounds so easy in real life this process
is not at all easy why not let's try to
understand so whenever we talk about
splicing many things should come into
our mind that how are the introns and
the exons are distinguished from each
other are there sequence features right
that would discriminate between introns
and exons second how are the introns
removed third that how are the exons
joined to each other after the introns
are removed all of these questions
should come into our mind when we think
about this splicing process which is
rather complicated so the mechanism by
which introns are excised
out is known as splicing and in this
video we are going to focus on few
things that what is the mechanism of
splicing where and when does splicing
occur what is the utility of splicing so
overall video have three steyr structure
first we are going to talk about this
icing mechanism the chemistry of it then
we would talk about well done splicing
occur and at the end we would talk about
the utility of the splicing but this is
a very brief and bird's-eye view of this
whole process later on we are going to
talk about this mechanism in details but
before that guys I want to tell you that
please subscribe to my channel if you
are a new visitor and don't forget to
share it in social media by the way I'm
also present in patreon so if you want
to support me please pay me in patreon
and be my patreon and my courses are
also present in an academy which is
India's biggest learning platform so if
you want to join on academic use my code
epi 10 to get 10% discount thank you
guys
now let's come back to the video so here
is a eukaryotic gene and let's look at
the Junction's of introns and the exons
it turns out the junctions of introns
and exons have specific signature
sequence which can be distinguished now
these are known as five prime splice
site and three prime splice site and
there is also another sequence feature
which is inside the intron known as
branch point so these sequences are
given like this particular so for
example five prime splice site has a
concern of GU sequence whereas the three
prime splice site has a AG sequence now
this sequence help the machinery to
recognize it but before that let's
understand the chemistry of it so let us
assume this is the simplified diagram of
the chain where blue are the exons and
the intervening sequence are the introns
and introns is is depicted very simply
now first what will happen is a
nucleophilic attack now let me tell you
guys the process of splicing is nothing
but two subsequent transesterification
reactions so there are two nucleophilic
attack and that's all but there are
certain machineries which are supporting
these chemical events but let's
understand the chemical chemistry first
and then we go to the mechanism of that
machinery so first from the brow
point adenine the two prime hydroxy
group the lone pair of two prime hydroxy
group would hit the GU bond so that is
the first set of transesterification
reaction so between guanine uracil there
would be phosphodiester bond which would
be attacked by these lone pairs of two
prime prime hydroxy group as a result
what would happen as a result these GU
would be forming a lariat like structure
and exposing the voyage group of the
five prime splice site now this Oh H
group can further work like a new
nucleophile and it would attack again
the three prime branch site the three
prime splice site and after that what
will happen the second transistor if
ocation reaction as a result the lariat
would be removed and the exons would be
rejoined so this is the overall process
the chemistry of the splicing event now
let me tell you this process is
complicated so the spliceosome machinery
is composed of hundreds of protein among
them many of them are snrnps the snrnps
are actually RNA so which are catalytic
in nature okay and the spliceosome use
ATP hydrolysis for its function
now the key components of the
spliceosome is ribonucleoproteins
because ribonucleoproteins are the key
factors in this whole splicing process
now let me tell you that this whole
recruitment of the snrnps happens in a
sequential fashion
now these snrnps and a spliceosome hold
the overall eggs on an intron in
position such that they don't once there
is a certification reaction they don't
move away so that's the whole goal of
this complicated machinery so they hold
it in position and let the transistor if
occasion reaction happens itself
now first u2 is recruited after that in
the branch point you one is recruited
then you two associated factor and
branch point binding protein associates
near the 3-prime branch site after that
branch point binding protein is
dissociated further a complex of u4 u 6
and u5 joins then what happens the first
set of transesterification reaction
takes place that means the two prime
hydroxyl group hit the phosphodiester
bond then what happens the 5-prime
branch the 5 prime splice site has open
hydroxy group which can further a hit
the 3 prime splice site right and then
ultimately what happens their exons at
rejoined and the lariats
along with these snrnps are removed
now these snrnps helped to hold these
complex exons and introns in a
particular position such that they don't
float away inside the cell right so in
this video we learned how complicated
snrnp mata is an RNP help in the process
of splices or splicing right now this
splicing process is far more complicated
and there are different type of introns
that are spliced out namely Group one
intron group 2 and group 3 intron and
each cases overall the mechanism is same
but there are some modifications and
some differences so about all of these
type of splicing event we are going to
look at in the subsequent video but let
me tell you guys the necessity of
splicing process so let me let us assume
that this is a gene and it has four
exons denoted in four different colors
now in case of splicing what happens is
different combinations of exons might
might be spliced for example here the
red yellow and green
might be splicing might might be spliced
out and forming this characteristic mRNA
and that gives rise to a particular
protein with a different defined
functionality now from the same
blueprint that means same DNA
if the
friend exons are selected for splicing
for example this blue one the red and
the yellow one then a different
combination of exons would give rise to
a different type of mRNA and its product
would be totally different and it has a
new function and this is how from one
particular blueprint you can have more
than one type of functionality in terms
of protein so this is very important in
terms of physiology and we'll come to
that in subsequent videos but let me
tell you guys before even the process of
transcription can stop the splicing
machinery started its work so when the
RNA polymerase is moving along the 5
prime to 3 prime direction and
transcribing the mRNA then the
phosphorylated c-terminal domain is a
site for binding capping enzymes and the
alternative splicing in enzymes and this
process happens simultaneously while the
transcription is going on so imagine how
complicated this process is and how much
temporal control this process requires
so overall in this video we looked at
the mechanism of splicing whereas
slicing occur and the utility of
alternative splicing so I hope you
understand this concept and this was
just an overview of this whole process
in subsequent videos we are going to
talk about all of these process in much
more details so stay tuned and keep
watching thanks for showing love and
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you